this episode is sponsored by surf shock
surfshock is a virtual private network
available as an easy to use app and web
browser extension it allows you to
access websites and content that you
would have otherwise not have been able
to see from your own country so let's
just say you wanted to watch the jake
paul versus tyrone woodley fight on the
showtime network you in the uk
potentially could switch to america and
watch it it also encrypts your data
which adds an extra layer of security so
that all of your activity is hidden and
your personal information is safe so
click the link in the description below
and use the code jody to get 83 off and
three months extra free enjoy the
podcast
[Music]
at one time i was homeless instead of
going home every night there was no home
to go to
life at home was very difficult i grew
up being abused
i lost my belt i lost respect i
embarrassed my family my vision was
pretty much non-existent i was able to
just about scrape by the medicals
i come out i have supreme confidence i'm
scared to death
i'm afraid of everything
i didn't care about living i just wanted
to die i got up and i felt the weight of
the world was lifted off my shoulders i
knew i was going to make
[Music]
my dream my vision for myself is to be
the greatest martial artist to ever live
i have always been a fighter there's
nothing i do better in this life than
fighting
there ain't never been a month like that
to me i was born to do this
nobody can get close i'm the best
fighter in the world i'm the most brutal
and efficient and more ruthless champion
hey jake what up bro how are you i'm all
right bro how are you man
i'm good i'm good man enjoying
enjoying the last couple days of camp
here yeah yeah where about your miami
yeah
i'm in uh puerto rico [__] you're still
in puerto rico with logan
yeah yeah he lives
right across the street
[__] oh man this is mod okay i'll
better set this [__] up uh this is
episode one of a brand new podcast that
i'm starting
called the pain game podcast which is
devoted to fighting so naturally you
know i found the biggest meanest disney
channel star could find
and
uh no i found one of the most talked
about [__] on in the fight game
and uh crazily you're about to fight
tyron woodley and back when
uh you start this journey fighting deji
when i interviewed you in 2018 tyron
woodley was the ufc
welterweight champion of the world
is that an actual step that is actual
facts
right so when you were getting
interviewed by me three years ago
he was the champ
and he he then defended it after u4
against edgy
against darren tale and he looked
unbelievable in that fight to be fair
tyron woodley i mean it was a [__]
amazing performance putting that in
perspective what does that make you
think that when you started learning how
to box only three years ago he was the
champion
yeah it's i mean bro it's to be honest
it's hilarious like how do we get here
and you and you've been there the whole
entire time which is
it's so cool yeah but
yeah i always say
you know
this guy has been boxing
longer than me
and so people i'm like how am i the
favorite how am i the betting favorite
this this is actually absurd to think
about uh
and people say fight a real boxer fight
a real boxer fight a real boxer
this guy has been boxing for longer than
me he was the ufc champion i always make
the joke he was ufc champion while i was
doing like the disney thing like
bro you you you were training for deji
when he was the champion
deji you've gone from deji if if i told
you back then when you were sat on that
table we did that podcast oh by the way
you're gonna fight tyron woodley in
three [__] years people aren't giving
you enough credit for this it it seems
like the world has just adjusted
mentally to oh jake paul can fight it
like no like i get that people want to
change their opinion because the facts
have changed like what you've done has
changed but everyone was slaying you and
now all of a sudden you're the betting
favorite against the welt away champion
tyrone woodley who
joel rogan said and i respect him as
much as anyone top three welterweight of
all time in the ufc
yeah this is legit as it gets bro this
is as legit is it
i don't know uh i feel like people give
you a hard time no for sure man but you
know
that's what happens when there's a lot
of eyeballs there's also going to be a
lot of critics so i get it i i
understand people's point of view as
well and i do still think i have a lot
of respect to gain from people because
they haven't seen you know my full
boxing ability they haven't seen
my ability to take a punch uh you know
so i get where people are coming from
and
you know we're just a few days away from
august 29th and i now
get to show them what i've been working
on hopefully you know people are like
hey what's gonna happen what's the
prediction for your for the fight and i
think i'm gonna end it fast but if i
don't
then at least i get some experience
under my belt at least i'll be able to
show
you know how good of a fighter i am show
my inside fighting show my combination
show my cardio
so i'm just i feel like i'm just getting
warmed up but it's already at such a big
level it's crazy
nobody's really expecting this to end
fast outside of your cam i think a lot
of people are looking at this going now
we're going to see
the j what jake paul is made of because
the path of resistance tyron woodley
should put up very least they're
expecting a couple of rounds where they
can see more of your weaknesses but do
you think that the reason you're the
favorite is just because
of you've you've had
an easy go of it in in many people's
eyes they haven't had any damage and
that sort of thing
yeah i think that and uh i think people
just
seeing how seriously i take it and how
dedicated i am to it and
how i've turned my whole life into this
you know
people were so used to the jake paul
like partying you know doing music
videos making youtube videos
getting in trouble i've shifted my whole
entire life around
into just boxing and i think people see
that and
i don't think people understand the mind
state of what you were as well at that
time it's like
it isn't you weren't just leading a
chaotic lifestyle because it was fun i
mean obviously that was part of it but
you knew
if i
make my life this way it will help with
content i i feel anyway that's the way i
always looked at you like you had a life
that was conducive for entertainment now
it's conducive to being a better fighter
no for sure you're spot on you know i uh
you know my life previously was
built around
how do we entertain the world if you
filmed my life now
for like if i like was vlogging my life
now people would be like this is the
most boring [__] ever
what is he doing like
he okay he's going on a jog okay he's in
an ice bath okay he's sparring oh okay
he's sleeping okay we're done here
they're saying they're saying daily
vlogging uh content right now uh so
let's go back to the ben oscar and fight
i mean you won me
fourteen thousand dollars
that night right legit this is no word
of a lie i knew you were gonna [__] this
guy up and i put i won poker that the
day before and i won seven grand and i
put it all i was gonna put one on you
and i was like god if i don't put the
lot on i'm gonna regret this because i
know he's gonna win so [__] it
so thank you for the money for a start
jake you you smoke ben but there was
there was a fair bit of action
beforehand that people sort of forget
because it was that killer blow when you
look back at that fight and analyze it
what do you think i think i was just
getting warmed up to be honest but
from what i what i was doing i was
striking good you know i was doing all
the right things in the moment there you
know just getting really picky with
myself there's definitely things in that
one minute uh one minute and a half
round where
i could have done better for sure uh but
but again that first round is usually
just to feel the guy out and to see
what's going on and uh
to see how they're moving to see what
punches they're throwing
you were very disciplined that was what
struck me is even though ben isn't
obviously known as the heavy hitter
you played the game how you should play
the game even despite what was in front
of you
yeah for sure i wanted to be smart and
you know i didn't know what he was
bringing to the table and
uh you know he was training with freddie
roach and freddie roach was like this
guy has
more power than i thought blah blah blah
so yeah i was just i was just being
smart and and
taking my time which sounds funny but
i i i really was
um yeah there was the body shot you hit
him with that on reflection i remember
thinking
that is a stinging shot that that's the
type of body shot that people would
never expect from you it was so it was
such a clever thing to do because he
couldn't have he couldn't have took that
and not have been thinking oh [__] i
better watch out for that and
immediately you come over the top with
the big right and that's the end of him
and i thank god the referee stopped it
by the way because he was a norfolk
state to carry on
i i was going to eat him alive
let him go oh yeah
the ref did a good job but yeah that
body shot was really when the fight
changed i saw it in his eyes you know i
when i hit him
he flew back and it was like his eyes
like popped out of his head almost and
that was his
his oh [__] moment for him uh and and
the fight was over shortly thereafter so
so let's analyze uh tyron woodley
because even though
i think some people are looking at him
like he's a washed up ufc fighter and if
you kind of
all right he lost a few fights in a row
but when when you look at the murderer's
role that dana white put him on because
the ufc were not woodley fans i think
business-wise he he may have been
difficult to deal with
everyone he fought like after the daryn
tillway was top five welterweights he he
hasn't become a journeyman by any
stretch of the imagination in my opinion
when you look at colby covington kamara
uzman you know gilbert burns and um
vicente lucay he put up a good fight
against them all i mean he went the
distance with his men and almost the
distance with covington for an injury if
you go out and do what you say you're
gonna do
a lot of those welterweights are gonna
have to look at you and go [__] like
i didn't do that yeah that's what i plan
on saying in my post fight win speech
just like look come on after i finish
him is like look tomorrow oopsman the
big bad
welterweight couldn't even finish this
guy and i i i did um and
so i think we will look at that and be
like oh man what's going on here
what's happening man yeah it's it's
going to be very difficult i think for a
lot of the mma crowd because they can't
keep turning on the people who lose to
you like
you know what i mean like that
tyron woodley i feel like has earned a
level of respect so
they can't just go oh woodley was trash
like you know you know woodley in trash
like you we you can't just trash the guy
just because he loses to you and i feel
like they're going to run out of excuses
if as you keep eating up these guys
and that's the goal right is with each
one of my opponents to
grow the level of competition and
at some point people aren't going to be
able to say anything you know
my brother went eight rounds with floyd
mayweather i think people were like did
not expect that at all bro the way
people were desperately trying to say
anything they were even like
clipping parts of the fight where he was
obviously putting his weight on floyd as
if he floyd knocked him out and then
helped him up it's like floyd was trying
everything he had to get this guy over
there i saw it first hand
lord was pissed yeah i could see it like
ringside he he was swinging hard doing
all these like dirty little tricks um
and and by the end of the you know
seventh and eighth rounds he was like
yelling at the referee and
you could tell he was doing everything
he could there's a clip of him in the
corner where his his his tournament says
work the job and he's like it's hard to
hit him really hard to hit him you know
so
i think you two are victims of the same
thing though you two could cure cancer
and people would be like yeah but
someone was going to do it like
you're just not going to get credit
really so
what do you feel like when you when
you've been studying tyron woodley's
career what do you see
um you know he
is always on his back foot
sort of
up against the cage
sort of striking moving backwards
uh so that's like one thing we we've
noticed a lot of and uh he's quite
passive surprisingly when you think of
the fact that he knocked people out yeah
exactly he's like
waiting for that one punch
being very patient
uh so you know those are those are the
some of the things we're picking up on
um personally i don't think that bodes
well i don't think that bodes well for
boxing because you know with that four
ounce glove you you know you can allow
the other guy to get a lead on you and
start but those shots those they build
up in a boxing match when it's about
more about volume i think and uh
he's gonna have to be a lot more
aggressive with you in my opinion and i
don't think that's in his nature whereas
it is in your nature and i do feel like
he's a little too happy to let the other
guy lead the dance
and that's some of the worst things i'm
saying from him right now you know i've
been in there with tougher guys than
woodley
and they haven't been able to land those
big big punches on me
and so
that that builds a confidence in me you
know if i can hang in there with these
guys who are faster and more skilled
than tyron
then i think the fight on august 29th
should be easy
and that's that's my mentality train at
a level higher than what your opponent
is uh
and the fight night becomes the easiest
day of training camp yeah if i was a
woodley uh fan
my worry would be is uh
also i feel like
if you get the lead on him and you start
dominating the likelihood of him turning
around is highly unlikely he once once
his head goes down a little bit and
fights
he stays in it but i think he stays in
it with a view of just don't get knocked
out just try and stay alive he doesn't
commit enough to really try and turn the
fight around and i think mentally
when i've seen you guys face to face you
seem to have an edge do you feel that
when you're looking at him in his eyes
for sure a hundred percent uh and i
think that will only get exposed more
during fight week you know as we get
closer to the fight you start to see
people's like real real emotions because
you can you could play a character but
even still i i saw a guy who was just
like
i don't know how to describe it but just
not not fully there in that in those
present moments yeah uh and not fully
understanding
what this fight is the the real telltale
fight of woodley's for me was that last
one vicente lucay where
everyone said oh you have to come out a
bit more aggressive you know this is
this is it if you don't win this one
you're getting cut and he came out
aggressive but it wasn't smart
aggression at all it was just
dumb if i'm being brutally honest and
this is and i'm not having a go at the
guy because you know he's done great
things but for his standards it was he
went from one extreme being really
passive to overly aggressive and he got
caught like quite easily even though he
was actually landing a fair bit up until
that point the legs were wobbly like so
bad like did you see the way he was sort
of like disco spinning towards the cage
at one point i mean yeah he uh he he
jumped in there he like bounced up like
a gazelle like with his leg bouncing and
being being wobbly uh and and like you
said he wasn't being smart at all
you know he he was landing good punches
but then he was just taking a bunch it
was desperate and and that's the thing
that you seem to be preying on a little
bit and saying
you know when you said that light to him
of like this is your last big payday do
all the deals you can because they ain't
nothing happening after they're staying
i really felt like that landed
for it's the truth you know and i'm and
i meant it when i said it like bro do
everything you can this your this is
your last payday
because i think i'm insane man but like
i work so hard and i've done everything
right in this camp because i know
what's at stake
and i know he is not working nearly as
hard i just know it
and and it's a that's the x factor with
you i feel like i i think because when
you don't know what it takes to be
a level of youtuber that you got to
where it was the daily vlogging and the
obsessed obsession that you had with
growing and becoming number one
when you apply that other things that
you're kind of you're always going to
succeed with degree and i feel like what
you're exposing more so than
people saying oh it's the level of mma
striking i think you're exposing
a lot of fighters out there think they
train hard but they probably don't
actually and
the group the growth that we're seeing
with you is is
i think exposing that you're just
obsessed and that's what you're
achieving right now because of that hard
work
100 like i i couldn't agree more um
you know i think i work harder than 99.9
percent
of the fighters out there i think i'm in
that highest percentile just based off
of what i've seen and i think i have to
be because of the expectation and the
standard
that
you know i have to live up to
and
the
you know i spar some of these pros i i'm
going on jogs with some of these pros
you know they come in
we do our thing they come out they go
out they're done
i keep on sparring i hit abs i hit neck
i'm stretching afterwards i jog home i'm
doing the ice baths the recovery like
i'm going doing the extra mile every
single day even when no one's watching
are you feeling more
like a fighter now that this is becoming
more routine and that you're is this
becoming normality a bit more
for sure i don't i honestly don't even
remember what it's like
to not be a fighter i think that moment
hit me when
in the ben askren fight
in the locker room before
my coach bj was like
hey guys get used to this this is what
we do now and i was like
damn he's right yeah this is what we do
now like before the deji fight i'd get
like nervous and i was so excited and
like what am i doing and then and then
they give fight cool and then they run
this and fight cool and then the ben
asker fights like bro we really just do
this now this is our job um and so
i think having that point of view of
like
i am
a fighter and this is my job now and
this is all i've known for the past two
years
it helps me so much
in the lead-up to these fights uh where
i think a lot of people like tyron or
some other fighters they might be
getting nervous when there's when it's
the biggest fight of their career coming
up for me i'm just like bro this is what
i do this is what i train for this is
this is my moment this is my time
in terms of jeopardy who do you think
has got more to lose here
um
me bro for sure
for sure
uh
high but high risk high reward you know
it time if tyron loses it's like
yeah well
you know at least he got paid and
you know he had a good career
but this is it for him and uh
you know
blah blah blah what else whatever else
they're going to say and then
with me it's like
laughing stock of the internet like
this guy was a phony every fighter is
going to come out of the woodworks and
be like
hahaha we knew this
was just a temporary thing
blah blah blah
so there's way more for me to lose how
does it feel to be signed a short time
now because that to me is
one of the things i don't think people
are grasping
the levels that you've gone to i mean
trilla
you know it was it was entertaining and
it was nice for what it was but this is
this means you're you're proper now to
me bro this is insane like it's it's a
dream come true when i signed the deal
with them i was like how is this real
um
[Music]
just because
you know they're the biggest name
in boxing right now and then to be
partnered with them is is massive and
it just shows you
you know the level that this has gotten
to and
the level that it still can reach
you know we're talking about
tyron woodley now
i would you know don't be surprised if
we're sitting here back on this podcast
in two years and we're like yeah so
you're 10 days away from canelo and with
showtime and you're getting paid 100
million dollars for this fight what's
that like you know what i'm saying like
that's very possible so it's just crazy
that like i've taken that
first step in that direction to make
this a possibility and uh it's a dream
come true of course what one of the
people tyron brought in for a little bit
of his camp was floyd mayweather
um
hey what do you think about that and b
there's a relationship there with floyd
and shorthair and everything that just
went down with your brother do you see
that being a potential fight for
yourself
i don't think i'll ever fight floyd i
think he realized like he should
probably retire and i don't want to do
exhibitions that's what people you know
i'm doing the real pro fights with
commissions and it goes on your record
um so that that's my interest and floyd
won't want to do that with me
i think his time is up
um but
you know
i think it's bad for tyron to be
training with floyd you know he's
bouncing around coaches going
here learning something going here
learning something going over here
learning something and then you never
really actually progress at any of those
things
and then it almost becomes a negative
it'd be better to train with one coach
get good at what he's teaching you and
stick to that you put the bet on him the
first time about his purse
uh he wouldn't do that he started you
know i'll beat your ass and uh and then
you put it on him about the tattoo he
said yes to the tattoo what made you
think of that what was the thinking
i just wanted to keep on pressuring him
to see what bet
at what point does his confidence
you know equal the equal whatever the
bet is
so i was just like i'm going to keep on
coming up with bets until this guy takes
one of them
he definitely didn't want to take that
one either like if it felt really
reluctant exactly he was like should i
should i do it
what do you guys think i'm like bro
what like are you not
confident in yourself
i think it would have been better if
he'd have said like dude i'm a real
fighter we don't do that sort of thing
the way he answered it is like
asking the crowd their opinion i think
that really showed a sign of i don't
know what to say here
you know yeah it's it's those little
signs of weakness that that i've been
picking up on
because if by the way like it whatever
bet he wants to do i'll take it so yeah
that's very clear
do you think he would he would stick to
his word if you beat him oh would you
even want him to would at that point
would you would you be demanding i want
to say this [__] tattoo
yeah 100 i have a tattoo
i have a tattoo artist one of the
biggest tattoo artists in the world uh
tattoo baby is uh is coming to the fight
and she has her equipment and so after
the fight i'm sending her to his locker
room to get it done
i swear
dude you are you're a doc but i like i
this is [__] this is entertainment
and that's what people forget is boxing
is
entertainment first sport second in my
opinion you've been training hard i've
seen some footage of you
and the real deal evander holyfield and
that i mean what is it like to be in the
gym with a legend like that it almost
feels like i'm in a boxing movie
or something like
it's hard to describe
but
it's so real um i mean you've literally
got sylvester stallone talking about you
like the guy who played rocky is
watching your movie play out now
that that that is crazy that was another
moment where i'm like what's happening
here
that was one of my like bucket list
items like crossed off yeah uh bro like
what
and he like knew about all my fights and
like knew my skills and it was like he
should fight mcgregor that was like
a such a crazy moment to be honest
yeah i mean all that does is it proves
your point and it like obviously the
numbers don't lie but when people like
that start talking it's like so that's
just the learning talk about like any
other [__] fight he ain't talking
about really you and mcgregor are the
most talked about fighters in the game
right now and that is insane to me
you could argue logan as well obviously
yeah no that that's that's crazy like
to even hear you say that you know
you're like you're such a credible
person and
like no the internet knows the game know
the business and the views don't lie bro
if i if i do a video about you with you
or or mcgregor that's hands down the top
two
that's crazy
hey let's go baby man respect me you've
done it despite i know people will say
oh you're sucking them off to me in the
comments i don't give a [__] like i'll
just say how it is and the facts are the
facts so
credibly you've been working hard bro
and that dedication is paying off and
one of the things i've seen that came
out in the last week was
a former coach of tyron woodley for rasa
harvey who i previously mentioned you in
the last show we did who picked against
you i think last time
um
he's come out and picked against you
again and he's also said which this
really pissed me off actually
he thinks you're on performance
enhancers i don't know if you've seen
this comment from him he didn't at any
point say why in terms of why he thinks
like he never said he looks a certain
ways you just said all those guys you
know it's boxing
and i just thought to have no basis to
say that really shocked me but i wanted
to know how it feels for you to have
that labeled at you
yeah i look at it as a compliment right
these mma guys are running out of
excuses
on why their guys are losing
uh and to to make a claim like that out
of nowhere just shows like he should be
embarrassed um you know my manager
texted me that i woke up in the morning
and he was like
uh george st pierre's coach
is saying that you're using peds
fyi
and i was like
i so i literally swiped my phone up went
to safari and i googled what are pete
what's peds
and i i swear to god like i swear my
mom's life
and
it says performance-enhancing drugs i'm
like oh my god like
these guys
these guys are trying to do anything at
this point to discredit me to make me
look stupid or to make any excuse and
what the the crazy part about it is like
dude these are real pro fights like we
get drug tested so
how can you even make this claim like he
you know it's
his point guys
when i watched the video his point was
that oh it's not as stringent as the ufc
testing but
you know my point to to return to that
would be
do your [__] research like how old
are you jake
uh 24 right you're you're very young guy
okay
since i've known you your your physical
body obviously it's changed a very small
amount from all of the uh the training
that you've done but it's hardly like
you've packed on 20 pounds of muscle
like
you know you're getting fitter you're
getting stronger but your body your
physique and i know that look there's
some stuff that it doesn't show up or
whatever but to me i just think it's so
unfair to label that at a kid who
is
performing and doing everything he can
he does you don't look in any way like
you're
much like
you know um conor mcgregor or any of
these guys that you've barely changed
physically and just throw that out there
with no
evidence to support it i think is so
he should be better than that is a man
who
who worked with george same pierre who
in the period where the ufc was drugged
up the [__] george saint pierre was the
biggest and strongest welterweight but
he was drug-free apparently you know and
george c nba campaigned
forever for for usada the minute you saw
her came into the ufc he left then then
he came back for one fight he said you
know what i mean so if you live in a
glass house don't throw stones to me i i
was really
as a friend of you i was a bit pissed
off at that because i'm like this kid
they're trying to take it away from him
before he's even beat tyra muddly no
exactly that's what i'm saying they're
running out of excuses and look i i
appreciate you having my back because it
it is funny man it's like bro i'm over
here eating like ice cream
you know these guys are accusing me of
doing
like sugars i'm like
bro i literally have a uh what's it
called uh a drumstick a vanilla fudge
drumstick
waiting for me after my run tonight like
all these these boxers are like
like don't eat junk food i'm like bro
i'm packing on some fat because i'm
going to drive that fat through tyron's
skull
like so that's what gives me my power is
the ohio milk like i grew up eating [__]
food and pizza like
it's funny man but this is the thing
you've you've always been an athlete
you've always been athletic and and like
as someone who's watched mma for years
where you can
you could spot a lot of the juice heads
the you know the the veto belfords you
know people like that you could say the
acne all over them the definition in
their body like you've showed zero signs
of any of this so yeah i wanted to bring
that up because i was pissed when i when
i seen such a well-respected guy talking
that much [__] in terms of the mma world
anyway um i've as always they're always
talking about you
and uh you you know you've um you've
brought up a few things one of those
being fight or pay
now um i i wanted to touch on this
because i think you've been winning some
people over with this and it's it's
quite interesting to see people go [__]
like this guy is using
his voice to speak out on our behalf
when the people who we we need to speak
out on our behalf as fighters the conor
mcgregors of this world ironically sit
silent as long as they're taken care of
but you're actually trying to be a bit
of a voice for fighters what made you
want to go that route look i mean i i i
see something that's wrong
and
in in the system and i didn't like it uh
you know i see how hard these fighters
work i know how hard it is to be a
fighter i know how expensive it is to be
a fighter
and
when i just see this tyrant in dana
white
just controlling these fighters like
puppets
and making them do whatever stripping
belts
not giving them the fights they want
not paying them what they want i'm like
bro [__] this guy and it became like a
personal thing for me uh and that's
really how it started and it was really
like a snowball effect it was like
something that needed to be talked about
for years and years and years that no
one talked about and then when i talked
about it everyone was like
yeah like yeah more of this and so i was
like
cool i'll be i'll be the leader of this
movement no problem um and i've always
been for the fighters like even on this
card all the fighters on this card every
single one of them
i made sure
that it's the biggest payday of all of
their careers
uh just
and that money is it's coming out of my
pocket at the end of the day um so
you know i've just always wanted to grow
this sport
and get it out there to more more people
and that's really my mission
interestingly when you and logan show up
at the ufc you get the vip treatment so
despite everything that you've said
you still get treated better than a lot
of the fighters under contract with the
usa that's [__] hilarious when you
think about it
it is it is weird you know and and it's
it's a sideways thing
uh
and dana white
knows that it's going to be a talked
about moment so he wants us at these
events and
it's all media it's all business it's
all sales
so so one of the main quotes that you
came up with recently was
conor mcgregor the most underpaid
athlete you know of this generation and
i i definitely don't disagree with that
but i wanted to put together maybe just
to give the the devil's advocate which
is
your situation where you've built the
binodians and then transferred over to
boxing
you know you you you did that on your
own so so therefore the ufc will turn
around and say you can't take 90 of the
profits because you brought that over
when conor mcgregor came to the ufc no
one knew who he was and we essentially
helped make him and without us he'd
still be on the dolan island that's why
we get to take such a huge chunk
of his cash uh what would you say to
that if you were in a sort of debate
with dnr in person or whatever i i would
just say like
is the amount you're taking still fair
maybe at the beginning when you were
both building each other up
then
okay
you take a big take a big percentage but
since conor has become
five
out of the top five biggest
pay-per-views of ufc history
then
you know you got to renegotiate and
dana's not doing that if he's got him
locked up he's not going to give him a
better percentage and so at some point
conor mcgregor outgrew the ufc by leaps
and bounds and just brought so much
value into the whole organization top to
bottom and created billions of dollars
of enterprise value
in doing so
and so
that that's why it's like
it's crazy to see that he's still at
their mercy he's still owned by them he
still can't do whatever he wants and
they're still taking whatever percentage
that they were taking
that is the irony yeah i mean you you've
hit the nail on the head there and i
just wondered if that's what you would
say because um
the year that conor had his champ champ
year and he won the two titles that was
when the ufc was sold for four billion
dollars or whatever and it was a hugely
he was a huge reason for that um because
he catapulted them
and i wonder if conor is a little bit
envious of you because you have so much
freedom and you know i've heard jorge
and mas vidal and the like you know they
talk about the situation of the ufc
basically give you a ten fight deal when
you when you become that way it's like
all right we'll give you more money but
you have to sign a ten fight deal so
it's like
you either sit on the sidelines and
retire
or you take the ten fight deal for
whatever money but you're locked in with
them and there's no and that's what they
seem to be doing right now with jon
jones and francis and gone who fought
and [__] march and
him and jones want to fight each other
but they want the pay and they're like
we're not [__] paying you you can
both sit on the sidelines we'll just
make a new champion
and i i as a fan it's [__]
frustrating because dana white's job is
to give us the fights we want and
because they won't give the fight as the
money they deserve we all end up sitting
there
and ironically all this does is make you
more of a main attraction because while
we're sitting there waiting for
heavyweight title fight you're making
all of this [__] noise in boxing no
100 and that's why it sucks it sucks for
the fighters
because they're the ones
you know that are suffering from this
and i think we'll see a new era
now
hopefully moving forward with fighters
get smarter they don't sign into long
contracts
and
we just see a change
that's what i'm hoping for
but in the meantime i'm pumping these
fights out
yes bro
yes um well conor mcgregor we talked
about him before uh obviously you've
seen the dustin poirier fight i seen you
send dustin the sleepy mcgregor chain um
again you i've seen a lot of fighters
who previously i'd watched people like
michael bisping's podcast and when you
did that like people were like damn i
get it now this kid is really funny like
and i think
it was genius that but what did you
think of the fight
um
embarrassing on so many levels for for
connor
uh you know he's just on this downward
spiral that he can't seem to to break
out of and i think it's because of the
partying
being drunk half the time and and really
losing the the motivation that he once
had
um
you know you you just see him
losing fans now
people are people are sort of sick of
the
of the person he's becoming uh and at
some point you know the [__] talk is
cool and being disrespectful can get you
more fans and people like it and they
get riled up and they choose a side but
to be sitting there with like a broken
leg you know and calling his wife
dustin's wife names and saying he's
going to murder him
you know
at some point it's just like all right
all right guy like
your time's up you've lost
you know however many fights in a row
now and when the actions don't match the
threats uh which is ironically what gave
conor his stardom which he would say i'm
going to do this and then do that like
when you lay there broken leg you just
had the [__] beating out you it's
look like the tough guy
you just look silly
exactly he looks dumb whereas he could
have been like a man and just been like
yeah [__] i just got my ass kicked i got
a broken leg and he would gain more fans
from that yeah what do you think about
the denial
what do you think about all that because
you know um it previously obviously the
nate diaz lost another losses it he well
mainly the nate diaz loss he took it
like a man and even after the last loss
against dustin he did but this time it's
it's like excuses and i mean he's always
had the odd little excuse but now it's
just as if oh doctor stoppage doctor
stoppage and all of that like what do
you make of all of that it's a guy who
was king for so long
and he's been dethroned and his ego
can't handle it and you just see this
short guy
you see the real conor mcgregor come out
and his identity is
is broken and
he he's just holding on for dear life
and his ego is taking a hit
and he doesn't like it
and that's what that's what you see here
yeah it feels like the
the money and stuff like that it it it's
kind of out of touch with reality and
even in terms of his fighting ability um
you know he's been having a go at people
like daniel cormier
who is a hundred pounds heavier than him
um michael bisping probably around the
same um you know um just
saying how comey is a fat mess and
saying things about bisping and all
these other things and uh actually
bisping made a very good reply which was
i don't know what he's deleting more his
tweets are his legacy yeah it just i
just wonder are you still interested in
a conor fight
uh for sure you know i i think it's
still
a massive fight i still think it is one
of the biggest fights that could happen
you know in the fight world today
um
but you know if he keeps on this path
it's like
it's it's just not gonna it's just not
gonna look good for him especially you
know he's going down i'm going up so
that's that's the thing is like by the
time he comes back
it
it may feel like a mismatch
and that's the crazy thing
no 100 and and that's it's funny when
i first called him out people were like
he'll kill you he'll kill you it's easy
and like
now
i i think tyron woodley is a harder
fight than mcgregor i agree i agree i
said this on a
video recently i said if he if if jake
goes out and smokes tyron woodley really
in in terms of actual competition
we know what's happening in the mcgregor
fight if he ever if you ever get that
because
woodley is bigger stronger he you could
argue he's even
more explosive than mcgregor actually um
if he if his punches don't hurt you and
you can get through that then i don't
see how mcgregor could drop you
exactly
we're thinking we're thinking on the
same wavelengths here so it'll be
interesting to see how this plays out
man but i have to take care of business
uh you know sunday august 29th and and
the history will write itself
what is your prediction for when
mcgregor does return to the sport how
would you say
because he thinks he's going to walk
into a title fight or whatever like how
do you see the the basically the end of
conor's career in the ufc
i think he'll come back again and and
get pummeled in the first round again
to be honest
i i really do uh
his chin seems to be gone
like even before the leg break he was
already like
he was already getting his ass kicked
yeah that's that's the thing that he's
sort of trying his best to not
acknowledge is
he's he's saying things about the leg
and whatever but
ultimately when dustin started putting
it on him he clinched first and he he
had to go for the gay team because
dustin was taking them down and and then
that was just non-stop ground and
pounding as i i'm i've been a big fan of
connor and i'm just sort of like you say
i'm sort of done you know i i just feel
like if he took that like a man and
shook dustin's hand i'd have been like
yeah fair play no i you know but when
you can't admit you've just been beaten
it
you get sick of that as a fun it's a
lack of reality yeah it's like the boy
who cried wolf you can only
you can only you know say so much
to the point where it just becomes
annoying at some point no matter who you
are
you've uh you've given a bit of a hit
list recently
which i find very fascinating and i know
there's there's some names on this list
that really seem to trigger people
uh i'm looking specifically at people
like canelo and javon uh davis
um
what made you put them on the list um
you know i think where this is heading
i i've just
set a goal of
i think becoming a world champion just
for fun
and
i love the way you word that [__] that's
going to piss so many people off
but
it would just be hilarious like oh yeah
everyone said he couldn't do it so he
did i just do it just just to prove
everyone wrong and just like yeah
i'm a world champion like whatever like
yeah i do this this and this
but
um
canelo
and jake paul just seems like a fight to
make because he's been in there the past
two times with guys who are
good on paper
but
who i believe don't
bring
the same level of a fight
that i can bring to canelo
uh you know i have a size advantage
and by the time that fight happens
i will be 10 times better than where i'm
at now
you know can canelo can only get
incrementally better at this point in
his career whereas i can get
exponentially better
um
so
i see that being a huge a huge fight
from the business side of things that
makes sense
uh you know there's only a couple
massive names in boxing and
uh he's one of them um
i mean the billy joe saunders fight was
interesting because
billy joe obviously looked pretty good
and then inevitably got got caught but
um billy joe doesn't hit hard like
that's just the reality of it you know
what i mean
um
and these guys are
fighting at 168 right yeah so
you know you get canelo in there with me
at you know whoever knows who knows what
weight class we would fight at
uh but there's gonna be a very very big
difference in size
uh
and i i truly believe i'll put up a
better fight than billy joe saunders
you know am i a better
boxer than billy joe saunders you know
time will tell but sometimes you know in
this sport
you just gotta make it a dog fight and
you the the the boxing skill goes out of
the window and it turns into something
different turns into heart it turns into
will it turns into determination and
uh
that's where i think billy that's where
that's where he lost the fight
and i understand to to a lot of people
watching this they'll think you're
deluded and crazy and and all of that
[__] uh but you know at this point i
stopped thinking that you were that
quite a while ago um beca you know and
and i think it's healthy to shoot for
the moon uh because even if you don't
get the goal that you're going for like
how far you'll go be so much higher than
if you just aimed halfway up the ladder
you know and i don't think people are
quite understanding that about you but i
guess that's because the way you're
built
no exactly you know
people think things are impossible maybe
for them
but i'm willing to find out i'm willing
to fail i'm willing to make mistakes i'm
willing to be proved wrong
and then fight back from there and
you know
and try and win still
so i think that's why you throw the way
you do as well because you can only
knock people out the way you have when
you're
not not afraid to be knocked out
yourself
a hundred percent
you the scared fighter never wins
uh you know you have to you have to go
in there
and
be the hammer not the nail
and what's training been like for this
fight then we we've really
you know kept it
pretty consistent with how every camp
has been
uh we've just
added a few
you know
different workouts
a few things that you know i've learned
to like more like i i liked swimming a
lot in this camp
because for me like getting in the ocean
and swimming
felt a lot like the fight it feels a lot
like sparring yeah i can imagine bro
because sometimes it feels like you're
it's going for you and other times
you're [__] struggling
no seriously like you're in the ocean
swimming you're getting your breath
you're getting your breath and then like
the wave comes
you lose your breath
all of a sudden you're underneath
like you know it's really difficult so i
i really like that this camp which was
something new we were working on and uh
but everything else has been good it's
the same old down here in puerto rico
focused uh as ever there's no
distractions down here so i've gotten
to do every single thing right and
before
even if i was in vegas or miami
there's still some distractions there
that pop up
one thing i've noticed about you is when
you throw shots
look that i'm not i'm not saying you've
got perfect technique in regards to like
billy joe saunders or someone like that
for example
but
for where you're at
your technique is fantastic for how long
you've been boxing
uh one of the reasons i've got to
imagine is bj flores and um
you know what is the relationship like
with him because now it's been a couple
of years and surely a lot of what he's
been teaching you now is really sinking
in and how is he helping you grow as a
person and a fighter
it's
it's uh it's unreal dude like our
relationship is amazing uh and it's and
it's quite literally a blessing you know
he's been such a guiding light through
this whole entire process
and
exactly like you said you know at first
you start slow and you start to pick up
on little things and then you get to a
point where
you can learn faster everything flows
off of the other thing and you can
actually implement the things you're
learning into sparring
um and so
you know he's been the the major key in
my skill and
and just my boxing knowledge
learning the sport understanding the
sport loving the sport
watching the sport
you know i feel as if now if i became a
trainer i'd be able to be a trainer like
a legitimate trainer yeah just based off
of how much boxing knowledge i have now
i i i've seen you train in some of the
kids on the charity day that you put
together how did it feel to have that
day with them and um do that
it was bro such a dream come true you
know i've always wanted to get to a
place in life where i'm able to give
back
and fight for something i believe in
you know a lot of people are like oh
isn't he a bull like yeah i was a bully
you know and uh
i realized it wasn't cool
and i think it's a huge problem in our
generation and more so that even the
younger generation of kids being able to
log on to twitter from a unanimous
anonymous anonymous sorry
twitter name
and
rip people apart bully people it's it
sucks
sucks to see
um
and so yeah it's my mission to be
leaving impact and
help fight back against bullying and i
see stuff where people are like when i
call out fighters now
they're like
oh well i thought you have a foundation
to like not be a bully like bro i'm
calling a grown-ass man and saying like
i beat him up
like oh this is this isn't bullying this
is like part of my job this is part of
the business could kids should random
kids
be bullying each other no
should can boxers insult each other yes
um but
yeah man it's been it's been really good
to see and
uh and it's very fulfilling you know i
got a lot out of that
that day
and when you they say when you give you
get
and it's the most true thing ever
and i think it's healthy that you admit
that you were a bully yourself at one
point because everyone's got the sub
story everyone you know everyone's a
victim these days but not everyone's
willing to admit that they were you know
the guy in the wrong and seeing someone
with your fame say yo i [__] up i did
this you know with so many people who
look up to you
i think it's great that you've you've
held and look who hasn't said something
[__] you've done something shitty before
in the past like that so
good on you mate thank you man no
exactly and it's and it's recognizing
that you know and sometimes people don't
even
think that they're bullying sometimes
you don't even realize it you know and
that's and that's what i want to spread
awareness on like i'm sure there's
people in the comments roasting each
other on this exact video
just think
just think twice before you send
something out there into the internet
because even though it's digital those
words are very real and they can affect
people for the rest of their lives do
you not think though that
for me anyway
you know when other youtubers take shots
at me or people leave comments or fans
or whatever
when you know you could knock [__] out
of most people who say this [__] if not
every single one of them it responding
and getting into that [__] it's so
like you must look back at the things
you used to do and be like [__] if that
was me now i wouldn't even reply or just
walk right right over the guy and give
him a good [__]
you know
for sure yeah you know
exactly and that's but that's part of
the the foundation is like
if you become confident enough through
the sport of boxing which is what i did
which is how i gained a lot of
confidence star boxing it's going to
grow your confidence to the point where
even if you are getting bullied then you
probably you don't really care i could
give a [__] what people say about me now
because i've gotten to this point but it
took me a while to get to that place and
boxing helped me get to that place so
that is
part of the foundation of why i think
more people should box because
you know
someone could say something but you're
just in the back of your head you're
like yeah i would beat this guy up
yeah i'm totally there bro like it and
obviously i i've always been a big guy
but in but boxing especially when you
get in a ring and you're getting the
crap beaten up with you by someone who
is a tough guy who is a hard guy and you
realize like
yeah i'm made of strong stuff me you
know and it makes you really evaluate
how you even say the world
um which ironically is why i call this
podcast the pain game because
uh the coach i was with at the time told
me you know there's only one way to
learn and that's to go through pain
um and once you do
you start saying everything a bit a bit
more maturely ironically which you know
fighting is supposed to be something
we're not supposed to do but i think
it's the most natural thing in the world
weirdly 100 man yeah what's the most
common misconception that you think
people have of you
um
you know i think the media has painted
like a very
bad image of jake paul just through the
different controversies and scandals and
things i've been through
and i've just i was just thinking about
this the other day
where
i genuinely from the bottom of my heart
in
99.9 of those situations i
am innocent as [__] and like
i i literally am getting framed or it's
making me look bad or whatever i don't
want to say 99 probably like 80 of those
good savings i would say like bro my
career has been filled with so much fake
[__] and fake media about me and all
these scandals are just people lying
team 10 members like all of it's just
like one [__] big lie about me but
the reason why is because it turned into
this snowball effect where oh anything
we say about jake paul people are just
gonna assume it's true because he's got
such a bad image already we could
literally say anything people like yeah
i bet that [__] did that yeah that's
so true
and bro like the for example the most
recent thing it's like the fbi raids in
my house people are like this guy's up
to some [__] this guy but he's a drug
dealer he's blah blah like whatever bro
i didn't do a single [__] thing and
they raided my house and i'm sitting
there like
this is crazy
and sure enough sure enough
months a year later they drop all the
charges yeah everything's all good like
of course because i didn't do [__] and i
feel like that's the story of my life
this person says that this person says
that this controversy this scandal we
hate him here this person said all of
it's a [__] lie yeah so to answer
your question
like
somehow i am such a like i'm a good
[__] guy i know that no one can take
that away from me and somehow through
the years i have just been slapped like
a [__] in the face
with the media and people just think of
me as like a certain way and it's just
it's not who i am unfortunately i'll
admit i was cringe i'll admit i've done
some stupid [__] made some stupid videos
i've i've you know gotten into trouble
here and there
but
and i've tried to learn from that but
like a lot of it is just yeah i tell
people this when people ask me about you
and i say actually
you're seeing a [__] very small
window of who jake paul is and when he's
hanging out with you he's chill and just
a totally
different guy when he's entertaining on
camera because that is that's time to
show up that's time to turn the volume
up but you know like anyone like you say
your life right now is just chill you're
doing your work and that and it ain't it
ain't what people think so i appreciate
you saying that and i know people will
try and you know
contradict you and all of that but i i
get your point and it's it's it's
similar for
i think
masculine youtubers especially
when someone tries to pin something on
you it sticks a lot easier if that makes
sense you know
um
i know yeah when you're not the victim
type of guy and you're not easily viewed
as a victim it's very hard to get
sympathy you know no matter what happens
to you [__] you that's what people say
um
okay okay so just to round this up bro i
really appreciate the time i know you're
training hard um
how do you envisage
the tyron woodley fight going um i think
i think it'll be a short night
my goal is to get out get him out of
there in less than three rounds i think
he's gonna you know come out
be pretty sharp
um
and try to assess
what i'm doing
but that'll be too much for him
uh to to even realize what he's got
himself into i think i'll hurt him in
the first round he'll make it back to
the corner be like oh [__] second round
i'll probably knock him down he'll get
back up
um
and then the third round
he just won't be able to withstand the
damage anymore i think as long as you
establish the job early on he's [__]
to be honest with you um
i think he's fast and and he's got some
nice moves but ultimately as long as you
you watch out for that right and you
keep hammering him with the job and then
you know do your thing where you look
when you got him with the right hand
i just don't see how he can handle
when i watch the performances in his
last fight and i see the power that you
have and i say what hurt him recently i
i say i agree with you and look
i know people might think i'm [__]
sucking you off and all of that [__] but
you know i've been honest with you and
when you [__] up when you said you
know we've always had that kind of
situation so i really believe that this
is another w comment that you made and
uh you know good on you good luck with
you
i appreciate it so much man and uh keep
keep killing it i uh i hope everything's
well in your life bro no i appreciate
you man and uh i'll let you go and
hopefully we'll catch up afterwards and
uh i'll get a little recap from you when
you're uh
making the next big fight
let's do it bro all right take care bro
and that was jake paul on episode one of
the pain game podcast
thanks to everyone who's been supporting
us
[__] so much lately i really
appreciate all the love you luck give us
i couldn't do this without you uh
honestly and with this i just wanted to
create something that was separate from
the regular podcast we had to do shorter
interviews catch up with some fighters i
know pre fight pause fight me you know
new fighters i haven't interviewed yet
where i can do a lot more specific to
the fight they've got coming up and and
i'll keep the true geordie podcast for
like the long life story stuff where we
get you know something's fighters
sometimes you know just lifestyle stuff
like that and this is going to be a lot
more
focused
on fighting mma boxing and the like so i
really hope you'll enjoy this there's
going to be plenty more coming out on
the main channel you can also listen to
it spotify itunes so if you haven't
already hit the like button subscribe
hope you enjoy this and i'll see you
later